Mr Beast is going to be worth over a
hundred billion dollars and it's going
to happen faster than you think so Jim
this is me calling my shop for you
there's eight points that I want to make
and stick around to the end because I'm
actually gonna react to one of his
latest videos with Tom Brady and Pete
Davidson over a nice lunch of feastables
never scoop dessert so first is he has
massive leverage in terms of what he
puts in versus what he gets out so he
may spend a million two million even
four million dollars on a video but the
amount of Impressions that that one
video gets across the world because he
also translates it is worth hundreds of
millions let me give you an idea of what
Beast Industries is all about in terms
of the ecosystem across like four five
six YouTube channels he's got 183
million subscribers and that doesn't
include the international channels which
are more than half of his audience
on top of that he's got Tick Tock he's
got Instagram he's got Twitter and in
aggregate he's got over 300 million plus
subscribers they're also incredibly
engaged
no I can't even hear in 2022 Mr Beast
had the fastest growing account on Tick
Tock and YouTube two of the platforms
that has the most eyeballs right now he
has the most of them you think about the
amount of creators on each of those
platforms and he was literally number
one on both his biggest videos are
bigger than the Super Bowl it's hard for
people to comprehend that on the
business side he's got Beast Burger
which is a ghost kitchen which basically
leverages the network of restaurants
that already exist and then he uses his
distribution base of customers to buy
stuff on an app and then it gets
delivered and filled on from whatever
local restaurants he's already partnered
with the next thing he's got Beast
gaming which is where he'll try and make
apps and video games because he has a
big gaming audience but I think we're
the real winner for him is going to be
and this is what I would make my bet on
is that he's going to be going all in on
feastables number two is that when you
have a media company your product is
your marketing which is one of the
unique advantages that only media
companies have meaning the more you
spend on your product which is your
media the more marketing ends up
happening if you don't know who I am my
name is
I make these videos because I hope to
attract other business owners towards us
that are doing over a million dollars a
year in profit so we can invest in your
business in office scale there's a ton
of Leverage for media creators because
what they sell and how they Market
themselves are one in the same and with
that leverage he's able to gain access
to other people's massive distribution
Paces he was surprised how much Joe
Rogan's podcast with him you invest so
much money into the show yeah I don't I
don't I don't why do I need money how
many older people started recognizing
him from that podcast he can get on Joe
Rogan he can get on flagrant one
trillion dollars I give you right now I
bought everything I wanted in life he
can get on impulsive because they know
that if he's on their podcast that
podcast will crush because he brings his
own audience and so whenever he does
knock on the door the door is open for
him number three is that cpg makes a ton
of sense for him because so many people
eat chocolate eat chips eat pretzels and
a lot of those people are in his
audience right now feastables is
probably going to pay three to four
hundred million dollars this year in
sales manufacturing chocolate bars or
chips or water is not overwhelmingly
complex compared to making a software or
an app or something like that what we
are seeing with feastables just with
chocolate is a drop in the bucket
compared to how big this brand will be
once he enters bigger more profitable
categories what I mean by that is how
many chocolate bars does the average
person buy a week
now how many sports beverages or water
do people consume per week and purchase
per week significantly more and so if he
goes into those categories even if the
same number of people purchased get 10
times the revenue he's currently getting
with chocolate bars and right now he's
selling out faster than any other brand
my team had to go to a zillion different
grocery stores and we still couldn't
find these nuts because they're sold out
almost everywhere he's taking up more
shelf space and pushing through his
product at a faster rate than any other
brand on the category it's been absurd
face whatever I thought we were gonna
sell we're doing like five times better
it's kind of shifted my whole mindset
like retail space when you have a brand
this big it's just so op if Jim has
realized the power of cpg and the reason
that it's so powerful in the influencer
space is that most people don't have
incredibly strong Affinity to the brands
that they consume most brands are really
old they just like have been drinking it
because they've always drank it not
because they actually made a conscious
decision I could go stand in any Walmart
in America and I would have to take 100
photos so those same people when they go
into Walmart will buy my products it's
just because people are like oh it's
that guy from YouTube and they buy it
but as soon as one of the influencers
that you saw come up and that you were a
fan of or even recognized you'll be more
likely to take it currently these work
out at 2 pound 90 per bar which is
obviously more expensive than your
average Supermarket chocolate oh it
smells good and maybe even pay a little
bit of a premium on top of the
Commodities product and you can measure
the strength of a brand based on how
much of a premium you can charge on a
commoditized product if I have two white
t-shirts and one of them has an LV logo
on it and this one can go for a hundred
dollars and this one goes for one dollar
then I have significant branding and
pricing power as a result of that well
right now the richest man in the world
Bernard Arnold owns the Sprint and a
zillion other luxury Brands because she
understands the pricing power of brand
and those gross profits that you can
generate for selling the same thing is
what you can then reinvest in Innovation
staying ahead and marketing even more to
reinforce the brand and that's what
becomes the brand flywheel is that you
to create a little bit of a premium you
make the spread you reinvest that into
The Branding itself then that reinforces
the brand you can raise the price more
increase the spread and then around and
around you go until you have this
incredibly strong brand that's
established that consumers in general
are willing to pay more for number four
is that he's able to monetize the widest
base of his audience at the most basic
level every single person who views this
video he gets some money off of his
media his content touches the broadest
audience which is simply entertainment
everybody can watch Mr BEAST's content
and so his products as a consequence he
gets to reach everyone with what he
sells but what's the level underneath of
that if someone paid Mr Beast for an
integrated ad inside of one of his
videos we have a very serious problem my
mom is currently online shopping and I
don't think she has honey installed on
her computer they believe they're going
to make significantly more than they
paid him off of that ad he would then
make more money promoting his own thing
and make up the Arbitrage you have to
try these nuts so if someone gets 10 to
1 or 20 to 1 by paying him 20 million
dollars a year to Market their their
thing then it means that he might be
able to get 200 million or 400 million a
year marketing his thing because it
stays within the brand and it's
congruent number five is that Jim is
smart enough to know that he doesn't
know everything yeah for the most part I
don't know what I'm doing trying to
absorb knowledge as much as possible and
I'll just call people I'll be like I
don't know what I'm gonna learn off to
you I'll do everything I can to add
value to you in exchange just teach me
everything you know like people who run
a snack business and I've done that like
five hours a day it's actually really
hard for me to imagine being one of the
most popular people on planet Earth in
your early 20s and not letting that get
to your head and having had many
conversations with him he's confident
that he can kill it but he's incredibly
open-minded to listening to people who
he feels has expertise outside of what
he has mastered he hits up people anyone
who he thinks he can learn anything from
and he doesn't judge the fact that he's
further ahead than some business people
because think about this if he raised at
one and a half billion or 1.6 or
whatever it was for Beast Industries
he's technically a billionaire on paper
why would he talk to somebody who's not
a bill dinner on paper because he still
feels like there are things that he can
learn from them and then Implement into
his machine and instantly get to 10 or
50 or 100. he still texts thumbnails for
his videos to some of his close buddies
just to get their feedback because at
the end of the day
he cares about winning more than being
right number six is that he's trying to
hire a god Squad and he's doing it
aggressively so he wants the uh Avengers
of business and content to be on his
team in-house he will do whatever it
takes to win no matter what he gets
people to move in with him in his house
so that he can indoctrinate them into
the Mr B's way of doing things which is
just when it all costs without hurting
anyone and do good while you do it smart
people recognize the fact that he's
growing like crazy and they want to get
on the ship number seven is that it's
amazing how collaborative rather than
competitive he is now don't get me wrong
he's super competitive as a person but I
think a lot of his him against him but
he's willing to collaborate with other
creators rather than cut them down he
helps people out on their first Channel
with no subscribers he does tick tock
videos with tick talkers that aren't
nearly as big as him he sees the world
as larger than a zero-sum game meaning
we can just both win and I think that's
actually been one of his low key secret
to success is because early on he was
masterminding with all these guys who
were all together they're trying to get
millions of subscribers and all of them
did we're all super small YouTubers and
we basically talked every day for a
thousand days in a row and did nothing
but just like hyper study like what
makes a good video what makes a good
thumbnail what what's good pacing like
how to go viral and we would just call
it like daily masterminds you know this
is me just putting my theoretical hat on
but I'll bet that him seeing that all of
them could win when they all worked
together and they all won faster and
bigger than if they worked on their own
probably changed the way he saw the
world in terms of how he creates and how
everyone can win together and number
eight is that Jim is playing an infinite
game and what I mean by that is that
he's in the game to play the game by any
stretch he doesn't need money anymore
and if you lost everything tomorrow
he would still make YouTube videos and
the reason I know that is because when
he had nothing he made YouTube videos
I'm always gonna be making videos yeah
100 I'm stupid and there's also just
like I'm like Predator this thing all
right have 30 years of my life I don't
care when I look at you like a parallel
storyline where I wonder will he ever
stop making videos yeah cause he's 25
now I know 10 years from now I'm like
you know I'm 35. 10 years from now I'll
be getting started and because he plays
the game that way he's gonna have one of
the biggest piece of Leverage that
everyone underplays which is time he's
already got almost a decade of
experience under his belt in his low 20s
in terms of like entrepreneurial years
he's actually older than people give him
credit for but still has
60 70 years ahead of him where he can
continue to compound that he's just
getting started and he's a master of
content and over the next decade he'll
become a master of business now let's
talk about what that means from
evaluation perspective a company that's
fast growing that has significantly
better margins because they don't have
nearly the marketing costs because most
times when the biggest costs in them is
inventory and marketing and so if you
can cut out an entire massive cost
center and get instant National
recognition or International recognition
the the potential of the brand day one
already becomes a billion 10 billion Etc
and for that reason I think that Mr
Beast will be a sense of billionaire and
it's also because he has so much time to
do it all right so I'm going to enjoy a
nice Mr Beast feastable chocolate bar
while I watch one dollar versus one
billion dollar yacht thank you and after
stepping on board it was pretty clear
why this yacht only cost one dollar if
you have to ask how much it costs to
carry a can't afford it you crack a
windshield it's like there's 200 Grand I
don't need this giant ship all to myself
so I wanted to share this experience
with you guys my subscribers
this is great you know everybody makes
interesting stuff and he's able to like
Find humor in everyday things and like I
just I always know like man I'm like God
I gotta be better
I'm not sure
used to be a melter if you like this
video then you'll love the next video
how you can get rich in the new economy
breaking down Kylie Jenner Mr Beast The
Rock and many others that are
capitalizing on this huge influencer
wave